foxnews has touted fair and balanced as
its motto
despite its obviously meaningless
reality for years and years on air no
more fox news is no longer using fair
and balanced as a motto my immediate
reaction was oh good the first step is
admitting you have a problem but is this
because they're admitting that they
aren't actually fair and balanced no the
network said in a statement this has
nothing to do with programming or
editorial decisions a senior network
official emphasized that the slogan was
officially dropped last August and
almost nobody even noticed and that the
reason they did it is because it's
closely associated with Roger Ailes the
now deceased former Fox News executive
and founder of the network he originated
the phrase he was fired in August in a
sexual harassment scandal and has since
passed away you're still going to hear
fair and balanced said on air pad in
case you were worried about that but
it's not going to be in graphics anymore
they have a new motto the new motto is
most-watched most-trusted yet this had
to be done of course because everyone
knew that Fox News is the right wing
channel and that's totally fine but you
just have to be open and honest about
that fact the problem with their new
model too is that it kind of you can
make the same criticism right because
it's not the most watched after the
ratings came out in May right and it's
certainly not the most trusted no and
how do you even really define that and I
actually go back to the Simpsons for
what I think the new slogan should be
the Simpsons jokingly used a fake Fox
News slogan in an episode where Fox News
was displayed and that motto was not
racist but number one with racist and I
think that is actually an accurate
slogan it's the one from the comedy show
and it's actually way more accurate than
the ones that they've been cycling
through and as Pat pointed out Fox News
is not doing particularly well right now
they lost anchor megyn kelly
they lost Bill O'Reilly this has taken a
big toll in primetime MSNBC last month
was the highest-rated Network in what's
called the key demographic which is
weeknights 25
54 years of age for the first time in 17
years and when I first heard Fox News
was no longer fair and balanced I
thought oh well that that that makes
sense it's sort of like when this was
the cigarette most recommended by
doctors because it has low tar it was
never a motto that really made any sense
yeah and people like Megan Kelly
actually defended the fair and balanced
mantra you have to wonder if they
themselves believed it and now that
they've gotten rid of it are going to
even push further to the right yet that
absolutely could happen and so you know
we're kind of joking around about this
but there's a serious angle to this
beyond the fact that one of the major
three cable networks is Fox News which
has serious to begin with false balance
false balance is an issue in media I've
talked about for a while Fox News would
sometimes be quote fair and balanced
with issues that didn't warrant being
quote fair and balanced Farren balance
essentially means with a lot of issues
they understand that the truth is one
thing but they have to give you the
bogus debunked side of that issue as
well otherwise it's not fair and
balanced and that's what we call in the
media world false balance or sometimes
it's called false neutrality there was
often an inconsistency they were fair
and balanced by saying well we balance
out liberal bias in media if you're fair
and balanced how can you be saying we're
balancing out other channels which are
all liberal and never really made any
sense it was a gong show all along and
listen this doesn't really change
anything but at least they're no longer
touting that I'm glad about that yeah
that fair and balanced line really did
encapsulate this idea of neutrality
versus objectivity yes in just one line
right and I've talked about this before
you can be objective without being
neutral neutral is a fabricated position
objectivity is looking at the facts and
making an assessment they are not the
same thing and this is where false
balance often becomes a problem in media